survivors and lawyers arrived at the
court in paris for the verdicts at the
end of the trial into the january 2015
attacks judges found 14 people guilty
of helping three gunmen who killed 17
people in the city
they were handed sentences of between
four and thirty years
three were tried in absentia
we are happy that in our country when
faced with terrorism the justice system
works
and the perpetrators were condemned a
lawyer for one of the defendants called
the verdicts disappointing
it's not very satisfying for the victims
yes sentences have been given
but what the victims wanted was to know
who were the real perpetrators
because it certainly wasn't those in the
court syed and sharif kawashi
shot dead staff in the offices of
charlie hebdo
and a policeman outside they targeted
the satirical newspaper
because it had repeatedly published
cartoons of the prophet muhammad
the brothers claimed the attack in the
name of al-qaeda
in the following days ahmadi kulibali
who had pledged allegiance to isil
shot dead a policewoman and four jewish
people in a kosher supermarket
police killed kulibali just hours after
officers tracked down and killed the
koashi brothers
who'd been on the run for survivors of
the attacks
and relatives of the victims the past
three and a half months in court
have been an emotional and harrowing
experience
the sana batilli hit customers at the
kosher supermarket
he said he hoped the verdicts would
provide some closure
the terrorists are dead but those who
supported them were tried and it's a
huge relief they were condemned
it's important for me and the families
of victims who need to grieve
the judge said that without the
logistical support of those found guilty
the gunman would not have been able to
carry out their crimes
the defendants have been given 10 days
to appeal natasha butler
al jazeera paris